countless media reports insisted
Americans use and discard 500 million
plastic straws a day it's about 182
billion straws in a year which means
that every single American goes through
well over 500 straws annually we were to
take all the straws we used collectively
in a year and stack them end to end we
we would reach the moon 90 times
specifically the media was repeating
data first Gathering reported by a
nine-year-old boy the child had come up
with the 500 million straws a day figure
by randomly calling a few straw
manufacturers on the phone and taking
whatever information they gave him and
running some mathematical calculations
that nobody ever checked and
extrapolating that Americans somehow use
half a billion plastic straws in a
single 24-hour period needless to say I
have nothing against this kid as a
parent in fact I can appreciate that
he's focusing his energies on this
they're certainly less productive ways
that a child that age could spend his
time but the question is whether any
adult any major corporation any
government should actually take marching
orders from a third grader